وقد وصفت حركه حماس قرار مجلس الامن
بالخطوه غير الكافيه التي لا تلبي متطلبات
الحاله الكارثيه التي صنعتها اله الارهاب
العسكري الصهيونيه في قطاع غزه خصوصا وانه
لم يتضمن قرارا دوليا بوقف حرب الاباده
الجماعيه التي يشنها ما وصفته الحركه
بكيان الاحتلال الارهابي على الشعب
الفلسطيني في قطاع غزه وقالت الحركه في
بيان ان الاداره الامريكيه عملت جاهده
خلال الايام الماضيه على تفريغ هذا القرار
من جوهره واخراجه بهذه الصيغه الهزيله
التي تسمح بحسب وصفها للاحتلال الفاشي
باستكمال مهمه التدمير والقتل والارهاب في
قطاع غزه واعتبرت حماس في بيانها ان من
واجب مجلس الامن الدولي الزام الاحتلال
بادخال المساعدات بكميات كافيه الى جميع
مناطق قطاع غزه لا سما المناطق الواقعه
شمال شرق شمال القطاع التي ت عرض وفق
البيان للمجازر اليوميه والحصار الفاشي
وسياسه التجويع
المستمره